Rinkyu wa Rai-chan It's a
complete move Cheek
Usamura
Who's permission are you trying to take out that panel
?
Shima City Rikichi No. The
car is heading for the city The car is a company
rv It's
moving toward the edge where the Kendo Okappakan is located I don't
think I can cross the legs, so tell the police
Abel
Weapons are kappa  I'm in the same class aiming for the direction of the column
Good luck!  Hey, I might have hit the
wrong person with the kit What
is a woman in a kimono and dried fish? Is that a ghost
?  Don't float away
[music]
Rear was
happening
anoano Line up It's
okay I wonder if it's alright
tar
menime I
thought I could escape  I
wonder if the enemy can't run away.